piece what is the art piece let's look
at these art pieces for some odd reason
this model is holding a body and it's in
a shroud say you know what it's
coincidence but why for some odd reason
there is a map that looks very very very
like
[Music]
Palestine
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana
waala brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well insh
brothers and sisters Zara recently has
been under Fire why well for some OD
reason their designers have chose
on a weird time or should we call it
coincidence they have chosen brothers
and sisters to do a art piece what is
the art piece let's look at these art
pieces uh for some odd reason this model
is holding a body and it's in a shroud
so it symbolizes a dead body around it
it seems like there's some chaos going
on like it looks like a war zone I mean
we cannot make this stuff up it look
like a war zone and we can put all that
to a side and say you know what it's
coincidence but why for some reason
there is a map that looks very very very
like Palestine yes it looks like
Palestine not Israel because I was
stolen Land from the occupiers it is
looks just like Palestine is this a
coincident no brothers and sisters
people right at the top play games cuz
they are brave they think they control
everything Allah subhana is a best of
controller like Allah says in the Quran
do not ever think Allah is unaware of
what you're doing yeah playing games and
doing this kind of stuff Etc that don't
think Allah is unaware of what you're
doing he only delays you for a day which
your eyes are going to stare in horror
and like Allah tell us in as Believers
we are going to be on reclining sofas
watching if they the disbelievers the
enemies of Islam who are killing and
massacre in committing a genocide and
massacre in Palestine have they been
paid back for what they did not only
that Zara should be boycotted I am going
to be visiting Zara with a few mandem
and we're going to be insh protesting
legally inshallah to show the reality
and Zara should be boycotted if you are
too concerned about oh but I shop in
Zara I shop in Zara I shop in Zara okay
I can be thinking ah but they do some
nice they some really nice Jumers I'm
not going to lie they do but my brothers
and sisters who have been blown into
pieces their blood is more beloved to me
of with all the zaras put together so if
you're more concerned about but where am
I going to go or make excuses of yeah
but you know how we're going to boycott
all stuff that's you you want to do that
no problem nobody can blame you like I
said there's evidence from the Sunnah
you don't have to if you don't want to
no problem but to me anyone that has an
atom with your heart and sees what's
going on with our brothers and sisters
Palestine will boycott as much as they
can I repeat again as much as you can
and you know your capabilities and you
can there are so many other Alternatives
so many other shops that we can shop
locally to buy our clothes okay so Bo
Zar and not only that watch out for my
protest that I'm going to be doing a
campaign an operation I'm going to find
the name inshallah where we're going to
go Islamic inah and legally protest
vocally in front of a Zara store not
only that the owner of Zara in Israel
invited a far right individual a far
right individual to have private
discussion about what the incident is a
specific is specific to the franchise
owner Joey schwabel a Canadian Israel
Jew National and chairman of Israel Zara
franchise Tamera hosted hosted a
convicted terrorist it Ben G at his home
in their leadup to the Israeli elections
although Zara has not made a statement
of distancing themselves from this
incident so you can clearly see they
have not they are not making his claims
and not only that the recent ad campaign
that they did with the uh shrouded
bodies again they're silent about it
silence speaks volumes you're a silent
devil that's what you are Zara for that
matter not only that the head designer
of the woman's clothing in Zara even
made certain comments certain comments
which you can read below uh blaming the
Palestinians you know as if they are you
know caveman you know you can see the
insinuation that she is making to an
individual who was a model as Zara and
you can see this is the attitude this is
this is what shocks me is these zionists
let's make very clear these zionists
okay not all the Jews are like them
these Zionist individuals because if he
was a true Jew who followed Judaism and
the Tor yeah Torah or or the tanak you
would not be you are in Exile you are in
Exile so you are going against your own
religion for that matter so you would be
following them but no so I'm talking to
the Zionist these individual in the
fashion industry the ones who own Zara
you can clearly see their agenda the
agenda is very very clear they do not
see Muslims or even Palestinians as
human beings so I ask everybody that's
watching this to boycott Zara and I will
be visiting Zara myself that sounded a
bit wrong cuz Zara is a female I'm
talking about the clothing brand Zara
Zara you need to watch out Madam yes yes
okay Zara watch out cuz we are going to
make sure that Muslims boycot and for
those who work at Zara who are Muslims
we understand your situation we just
seem for the best of your ability if you
have an income you have to make an
income it's your livelihood
understandable but to the best of your
ability boycott Zara it is on the list
okay I asked the Muslim brother and
sister to the best of your capability
boycott Zara boyot Zara either you care
about your NFS or you care about
brothers and sisters who have been blown
into pieces and what's going on there
put your heart put your mouth Yes action
is what we need okay that's what we need
I've been boycotting products like
coocaa which I never drank anyways Pepsi
which I didn't drink anyways Costa
Coffee Starbucks I never drank anyways
Zara if needed be even KFC I'm going to
be visiting these stores one by one I
know there are alternatives to all of
these products we can do it but if you
are too con too concerned about your
comfort and this that you go ahead and
do that but I'm going to inshallah with
the rest of the people and don't trying
to have a high here stand in front of
Allah that I did everything to the best
of my C capability to the best yes I'm
going to try my best that is what I'm
asking you guys we can do this and hit
their pockets there is nothing that look
would look better on me of any clothes
in Zara than the clothing of boycotting
and hitting the pockets of these
criminal Massacre genocidal war
criminals that is for that matter I ask
you guys brother sister to do that and
keep an eye out when we visit Zara
inshallah and we are going to show you
and show the whole world that the
Muslims have the power for myself and my
baby daughter in the background you can
hear till next time
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said whoever builds a Masid for the sake
of Allah subhana tala Allah will build
for him a similar house in jenah on that
day where Allah subhana tala tells us
that our books will be given and every
little atam weight of Good Deed you've
done will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person and Allah
says this is for you for me yes what did
I do you allowed people to pray you
built a Masjid I never had the money to
build a Masjid Allah you helped you gave
towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if youve built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra
[Music]
Rewards